japan's got two big problems aging
population and in fact to the point of a
shrinking population and second high
levels of debt to GDP and both these
issues interact with one another and and
and so it makes the debt issue worse
central bank easing isn't going to
address any of those issues it might buy
the country time to deal with those
issues but it's not a substitute for
more structural reform and I know for
example Japan's tried to get women more
into the workforce that's an example of
an appropriate structural reform but but
I don't think central bank actions are
going to solve this they might buy them
time but they're going to have to deal
with these structural issues and that's
probably true of central bank action
more generally in advanced economies
they can buy time they can be helpful
but they're not going to deal with deal
with strut real structural issues do you
think that's why the Bank of Japan
decided not to move it could be and
because there are ripple effects from
negative rates on financial institutions
on savers and the reality is you know I
know it's I don't think I think it's
independent of this but they certainly
didn't expect the yen to strengthen as
much as it has right and there's a cost
to having negative rates so it doesn't
surprise me that they may be decided to
wait a little bit for some of these
effects to unfold a little bit more for
they decide on their next move